first day on Wall Street give him time
he's the messenger that is bringing me
into the depths of hell I remember
reading when I said who the is this
guy if this guy's serious about that
well I can write a book on this guy the
imagination just soars he brilliantly
came up with this sort of Rewritten
monologue that was so outrageous they're
in a five-star restaurant he pulls out a
bump of coke takes it orders martinis uh
until they drop and also let me tell you
this The Secret of this business is
cocaine and hookers my friend Barnes
Chris says he loves funny the last few
takes he and I didn't even really speak
that much English he was just doing
sounds
and he loved the non-verbal things that
I was doing Bang Bang
digital